hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
manga today I'd like to have a brief
discussion about the recently completed
the rising of the shield hero and take
note this is not a review or a why you
should watch I might make a separate
video for something like that but
instead this is more of a somewhat
coherent probably not rambling of my
thoughts on the series as a result there
will be spoilers lots of spoilers so so
many spoilers so if you haven't seen
shield hero and you plan to I highly
recommend coming back to this once
you've had the pleasure doing so on the
other hand if you haven't seen it and
you're still here for whatever reason
then well good-good fear pleasure to
have you and regardless we're going to
get straight into it now first of all
just some basics shield hero is another
in a long-running line of ISA chi jean
rather can be extremely hit and miss and
as a result it can sometimes be a
detractor to sell a show as an ISA guy
to me anyway but I believe that shield
here are quite firmly evolves and
elevates the genre for most of its
competitors it's a fantastic step in the
right direction but it also does most
certainly have its flaws and I'd have to
say that as a result my overall feelings
on the show are a bit mixed because
there was quite a lot about this series
and this world that I am very much in
love with but also a lot that really
takes me out of it and we'll go through
the good and the bad but I'd like to
start out positively and there's no
better place to do that then right at
the beginning shield hero had me
completely hooked from episode 1 I
really enjoyed the premise of a basic ki
Sakai setup only to have our protagonist
now whom he betrayed so thoroughly and
immediately set up on a completely
different path to anything that we or at
the very least I know and it managed to
achieve that by providing the character
of mine and you know I don't think I've
ever come to despise anyone so
powerfully in such a short amount of
time and that is absolutely brilliant
because it forms a strong emotional bond
between now Fumi and the audience we are
bound together by our pure rage for this
character that I was so immediately
compelled to devour the rest of the
series and watch now for me hopefully
take revenge it was one of those rare
situations where I found my feelings
very much in sync with the protagonists
most of the time when now for me was
angry I was also furious be it at mine
or the king or whatever but my direct
feelings for being conveyed by now for
me on-screen and I think that's a pretty
powerful experience definitely not
something to be underestimated
so immediately shield hero succeeded
when many other yokai fail by providing
a main character I actually care about
as opposed to a more or less empty
vessel that I'm supposed to insert
myself into and live vicariously through
I mean now Fumi actually has a
personality that he's forced into very
quickly adapting to the role of
Gai which i thought was a great
direction to be taking him in a proper
underdog story where we actually have
the potential satisfaction of revenge as
well as the intense exploration of rage
unfortunately though this did not quite
last and as much as I was still on board
but now for me for the entirety of the
series eventually does slip into a more
conventional named protagonist role and
sadly he's not the only one that suffers
with time his counterpart heroes also
began the series with exceptional
potential but really they were all
completely outclassed by now for me in
no time at all and I think that mama
Yasu in particular was turned into just
a little bit too much of a dumbass like
there were points later on in the series
where it just became frustrating to
watch him confront now for me over and
over again on the basis of increasingly
obvious lies and the same goes for eat
Sookie and rent as well because they're
touted to be the smarter ones of the
group but it takes them entirely too
long to actually suspect that now Fermi
might be getting framed especially since
they uncovered Minds underhanded tactics
in Episode four of the series
episode four and there's a bunch of
other stupid issues as well my cow in
the first episode they were portrayed to
be analytical and intelligent enough to
discover that they were all from
different versions of Japan but towards
the end of the series the four of them
couldn't even figure out that they all
had different ways of using their
weapons in regards to the rarity or the
copying power etc they just became a bit
plain I guess but for the most part I
did really enjoy the dynamics and
conflicts between the four heroes plus
their designs were pretty schmack and
always an aesthetic treat to see on
screen while we're on characters oh this
is probably good time to talk about the
whole the whole lower thing shield hero
very clearly sets itself in a world of
lolicon fantasy but you know there's
just no hiding from it when all three of
now Fermi's party members are
prepubescent girls even if one does grow
up rather quickly they really don't want
to go any deeper into this issue but
shield hero kind of forces you to
because it is apparent at all times
after episode 1 and this is probably the
biggest attracting factor of shield here
for me I think being an anime fan for
far far too long now I've grown
accustomed to the idea that series like
this will probably have one lowly
character you know just to fill whatever
requirement Japan seems to have in
regards to appealing to that audience
but this is probably the first show I've
ever stuck with that goes so out of its
wait cater to that niche and it is a
credit to the world and the story
because if either of those factors had
been anything less than great I would
have dropped shield heroes long ago and
I'm not saying that these characters had
no value either
for example Fela was great but I found
myself mostly enjoying her and her
fellow lio form because she became
powerful and funny
whereas
found her quite boring in her human form
and I know that this is probably
ridiculous to say when discussing anime
but I'm about to use the r-word so
beware look in general I just don't find
underage girls fighting against the dark
threats of the world in any way
realistic there we go I said it at least
not in a series that's first episode had
me hooked by presenting this dark and
mature setting adding innocent ish
little girls don't really contribute to
that atmosphere unless you're a tortured
slave like ruff Talia oh you know here
gurashi in general i guess but i said
before i found myself willing and able
to get over that because this world and
many of its characters were just so
compelling I really enjoyed the concept
of needing to fight off wave after wave
of ever-increasing danger you know it's
that basic mechanic I feel like I've
played in a billion different games but
it works so nicely if anything my only
complaint in regards to them was that
there was not enough wave action really
after each wave I just wanted more and
that is a great credit to the story and
it's anime adaptation I will say that I
believe the first half of the series is
far superior to the second though and
it's purely through pacing it felt like
such a wild ride going through the first
12 episodes with such rapid progress and
each episode felt so jam-packed full of
stuff but things did slow down a fair
bit after that especially during the
whole poke fight because I swear at
least two whole episodes were spent with
everyone literally just standing around
talking about character stuff as they
stared into their very potential
impending doom but it's not just that
because I did notice that in the second
half I main characters have a tendency
to get sidetracked a lot like if you
were to map out their journey after
they'd fought the second wave now Fumi
and company initially set out on a
mission to upgrade the classes which
turns into a flee to another country
which gets turned into no let's turn
around and meet Queen which gets turned
into a grudge match against ruff Talia's
former Hoonah which then becomes about
filo in the folio Queen which then
becomes reunite with the heroes and
fight against the battle probe and I
really missed the direction that we'd
had previously in the first half of the
series because back then when our main
character said they'd do something they
got it done and it felt like nice
progress whereas the second half is just
a constant barrage of being sidetracked
and yeah all of these ever-changing
goals are very important to the plot and
certain characters but after some time I
do recall saying to myself oh my god are
they ever actually going to do something
that they set out to do but even with
that said these constant distractions
are admittedly pivotal and quite
enjoyable and I particularly loved the
concept of the folio queen who despite
absolutely absurd power I have never
seen a bird kick that much ass before
and it makes it all the more foreboding
when you realize that not even that will
be
enough to stop the later waves I love
that sort of thing until it turns out
that of course the queen is also a loli
because that's just how this series
works actually you know what some great
characters who aren't lowly shuffle on
in at the very last second being Locke
and threes and to that point in the
series they were a breath of fresh air
that was so sorely needed because we
were making no progress whatsoever
without other three heroes so they're
injection of energy and antagonism was
very much appreciated they also came
with the welcome revolution that the
four cardinal heroes are not the only
heroes in existence which just thank you
that decision has infinitely expanded
the possibilities of the series and is
one of the reasons why I am so excited
for a season two but joy if it is coming
out at all for a long while now so I
will more than likely dive into the
light novels if they're readily
available but I suppose we're not done
with controversial topics just yet I
came into shield hero about halfway
through the seasons run so I feel like I
missed a lot of this but apparently the
show was criticized initially for the
way that it depicts slavery as well as
for the whole false rape accusation and
looking back on it know that certainly
is one hell of a way to conduct your
first episode with two incredibly
potentially sensitive topics it's the
sort of thing that could really tank a
property if it were mishandled but I
think they make a lot of sense within
the world and it does help to provide
the super dark atmosphere until there be
something incredibly serious against now
for me because I've thought about it and
I'm not sure what else really could have
been done apart from your stock standard
murder to really turn the whole world
against him so yes I suppose mine could
have murdered someone and framed now for
me for it but I just don't think that we
would have achieved the same feeling of
pure rage because as a society we're
quite desensitized to death especially
in animation and also it would have
brought a third party into things rather
than crafting this profoundly personal
conflict between now for me and mine and
as for the slavery well there's less of
a defense that I can come up with there
I mean it's legal in the world the slave
trader is a dick and yet he appears in
the opening is if he's some lucky good
guy a lie but none of that really
bothered me because of the path I
thought that the show was going down
after the first two episodes I thought
that now for me was going to be forced
into some really dark stuff with slavery
and the concept of owning slaves being
but one example but sheild hero doesn't
stay consistent with this tone and now
Fermi really falls into the role of
classic hero by the end with his only
dark aspect being the raid shield so
yeah it's a bit weird to think about but
the arc of the slaver and arrears he
stumbles upon now for me and by the end
of the series his business is better
than ever
trafficking lives away photos noses
blood nefarious purposes so with that in
mind I'm very much hoping that things go
back to their dark roots in future arcs
that tone was a really big part of what
hooked me into the series in the first
place
speaking of arcs though it's pretty
difficult not to highlight the fact that
shield hero had a very very natural
ending not episode 21 like it
legitimately felt like the series was
over only for me to discover that there
would be another four episodes and it's
really weird because they do a whole
heroic goodbye and embark on to the next
adventure and then in the very next
episode they've been called back and are
chatting with everyone that they say
goodbye to however I am glad that the
series didn't end in episode 21 because
the next floor episodes were very much
needed in my eyes and episode 25 in
particular gave us a much more
well-rounded ending that really brought
everything the series had been working
for up until that point together so what
else can I say
in the end shield hero was a super solid
series I actually fear that these
thoughts may come across as a bit overly
negative but that's because I have a
habit of getting hyper critical when I
find a story with some incredible
potential and it's because I want it to
be that perfect existence but even with
everything I consider a floor shield
hero has accomplished something pretty
incredible with this 25 episode run and
I cannot help but just immediately want
more that pretty much does it for my
final thoughts from the rising of the
shield hero if you enjoyed this video
when the content this channel produced
in general and please do consider
donating to the New World review patreon
because the sport of all of your amazing
people is what continues to make this
show possible in the patreon isn't quite
your style then please do leave this
video a like share or subscribe because
it also helps spot this channel an
incredible amount and if you'd like to
join the fun at any time then please do
head over to my discord server where a
wide array of shenanigan read takes
place on a daily basis and finally
please do comment with your own thoughts
from the rising of the shield hero this
has been the new world review and I'll
see you next time
[Music]